if you don't write and let's use that as
a metaphor for whatever all of the other
things that people might do if you have
a great joke on your mind then you don't
follow through on it
that's not a benign action you know that
Joe that Unwritten joke
goes into a bad Channel inside you and
becomes I'm absolutely convinced of this
and becomes cancer you know it becomes
something like it's must get out it's
like a living thing like it like if
we're if we're female and we're giving
birth and we're pregnant and you cross
your life it's a living thing that's
inside us like the alien yeah you know
yeah that's gotta get out and until it
gets out nothing good happens